but it's also the 15th anniversary of
xbox if you guys can believe it uh today
it's not even this week like today was
the official launch of the original xbox
2001 yeah it is crazy so i'm joined by
scott butterworth flow and jake Decker
how's it going good man it's good yeah
just trying to sort of silo myself in a
world of video games and keep my head
yeah coordinated wants to be like
everything's terrible let's talk about
that but I I agree escape this is
something that some people need right
now right so James let's look back to a
better time yeah the xbox one launched
in November 15th 2001 a few short months
after the Dreamcast was basically
discontinued and there was a gap in the
console market and here comes Microsoft
with a massive heavy machine yeah with a
controller almost the same size yeah the
Duke right so yeah I think so I thought
I came over that was the official name
or just the nickname I think that may
have actually been the official internal
yeah cuz the s like be much more like
boringly named s was the follow up
control that was much smaller and which
is more will be in general yeah it did
improve over time yes yeah you could
knock someone out with the smaller
control guys I'm sure it was such like I
don't know such an easy to mock thing I
remember there being like this is the
early days of internet memes right but
this was already like a huge running
joke anywhere you want on the Internet
deservedly so that controller was
terrible but the console was like
shockingly good yeah I mean for me the
biggest thing about the original xbox um
was just going into it feeling so
skeptical like just scoffing at the
notion of this PC company stepping into
the console markings I was in high
school at the time so I was like still
had a bit of that like fanboyism in me
yeah and you know had been a big
Nintendo fan growing up i'm just like
Judas Microsoft think they are making a
console this is this is ridiculous this
will never work well an especially like
after a couple years of playing
dreamcast games like I in particular was
in love with the Dreamcast and so I was
heartbroken to see it go yeah and yes
here comes Microsoft of all companies
with a brand that is this sharp green X
it looks very aggressive like it just it
didn't make sense it didn't fit into
what I think a lot of us thought
consoles were in part because Microsoft
wasn't a console company right like
they've worked with software mostly they
had some hardware experience but this
was their first jump back into that yeah
after a long time
and the console admittedly was kind of
strange right it was like super powered
but it wasn't refined it was basically a
pc in a little box but yeah because it
was so powerful we got a game like halo
combat evolved which kind of evolved a
lot of things about console gaming by
making it you know competitive with pc
in the sense of competitive shooting
being a thing did you guys have like
fond memories of that cuz i was a
playstation 2 dreamcast guy xbox kind of
washed over me until 360 360 was
definitely more of a big deal for me
well actually now and i want to point
out one really really important thing
about the original xbox that dovetails
nicely with what you are saying is the
arrival of Xbox Live a year later so
that didn't happen until I think exactly
you're after the original launch but
Microsoft was arguably the first company
to get an online network right like you
could play games online on dreamcast and
you could play games online on you just
Liam's online all the way back to the
NES because well yeah technically where
people were you playing online me no but
in Japan there were games that would use
like it wasn't because it wasn't any
direct sense that you're thinking but it
was like you know the the start of that
yeah but yes Microsoft certainly
established like look here is a front
area like a software like you know
basically space that you can access all
the stuff he was a dedicated you I yeah
you gotta framers right exactly yeah
like that was new and that was amazing
and halo was a big part of like that
that the marriage of those two things
like halo 2 plus Xbox Live was like it
was the biggest thing on consoles for
years yeah yeah I think bungee was
really kind of what figured that out
with halo 2 like Microsoft had the
infrastructure for Xbox Live and then
bungee was what actually put those
pieces together and had like I think
they had friends list first and like all
that kind of stuff yeah although even
the original halo like you're mentioning
like I remember playing split screen in
college that live with a bunch of people
like I I personally never owned an xbox
but I lived with people who did so I
just played all of their games and I
remember like coming home after class to
find everybody just sitting on a couch
playing hey green halo like the tiny for
boxes on her crappy television even that
was just such a joy at the time yeah it
was it really came in and over
past it actually the the xbox was a much
stronger competitor to the PlayStation 2
really was going right
arcade games which is what Sega was
basically still courting yeah
after me
in cast
so
or publish on the Xbox as well uh
shadows do
if yes your right to get that close what
actually came on a nice box but you
could they eventually ported that
anyways um yeah but so let's talk about
the xbox 360 now because that was
obviously where Microsoft like you know
they were established at that point and
when the 360 came out was well ahead of
everyone else yeah and they certainly
you know they found a way to make a
smaller console and with that they ended
up launching like really really big
series like gears of war and we didn't
mention fable at the beginning as well
but fable you know again continued on at
360 as well as halo and blossomed quite
a bit but we also got things like the
Kinect mmm you know like well not
everything was there have been some I
think every consoles endured a few
missteps right and we even if you look
back at ya like I mean poor r.i.p
Dreamcast in general right like it was a
little too ahead of its time and like
Sony's that just as many stupid
peripherals that completely failed right
i mean that that happens but i think
most of Microsoft failures didn't come
until later and i think that the the
launch of 360 on the heels of i mean it
was very clear they learned a lot of
lessons from the original xbox i mean
the original xbox was really powerful
machine as you pointed out but unrefined
in 360 was okay what if we polish these
edges and and offer something that's a
little more friendly you could argue
that's exact same thing that Microsoft
did in the 80s and that's why you know
windows became the standard operating
system over was arguably like yeah that
was part of what led to the company
success in the first place so they kind
of did the same thing again with the 360
yeah like I still love the blades
interface like I I think that was a
really great were that original yeah I
really liked it so they clearly learned
some lessons they also launched it a
year before the ps3 which I think would
help to law and the price like it we had
a Chrysler much lower you guys are you
guys are leading me so well you don't
even know both of the things you just
mentioned it's fair to say those are
probably the reasons why the red ring of
death became such a problem for
Microsoft because then they cut back on
manufacturing costs and they rushed her
product market before they were able to
really test it to the extent that it
needed and I can't even count the number
of rhetoric xboxes we've had in this
office yeah i think when i joined we had
a stack I'll have three you have three
personally read by myself I got so lucky
my original 360 didn't die until like
God I think after i had a ps3 actually
like it lasted a very long time it was
it hung in there so
lucky you yeah no I did I got very lucky
but I also I'd like my very first job in
the industry ever was I was an intern at
the official Xbox Magazine and I
remember we had a stack of red rain
decks taxes like a little just like oh
yeah we had we had at least like a dozen
here in the office deadly it was madness
and from what I remember Microsoft was
pretty good about it like you could
actually send them in Xbox and
frequently you could get it repaired but
it was only within like a three-year
warranty i want to say so some people
totally got screwed there was a date so
yes they would send you like a
self-addressed box that you could send
back and there were certain people where
if he bought it after one date they
would extend your warranty for a year
mmm so Nina they did a pretty good job
of picking up the pieces like definitely
but they also took a huge loss yeah well
and it should have been a problem in the
first place like it's crazy that that
was like a this major consumer product
was just inevitably failed like that's
nuts haven't seen something like that
again since maybe like the samsung note
7 recently right right that's the kind
of a different story in a way it was
just like third-party batteries it's
kind of different but similar you're
right like I'm yeah oh you're on this
huge scale yeah so Microsoft is
obviously still going very strong with
the xbox one and in particular the S is
sort of like really boosted sales for
them that's really helped helped out I
think from a product design standpoint
but also just because it's cheaper now
and it's been out selling playstation 4
rather consistently over the past few
months but here again we see microsoft
maybe going back to their old ways when
you know all the stuff that is now
exclusive to xbox one from them is going
to be playable on pc as well so the xbox
one at this point is sort of more of a
platform than a console in a way yeah i
mean they're clearly going for like the
unifying their synergy synergizing their
brand it's smart i mean i think it's
about time a company said absolutely
yeah yeah but yet i think that this this
current console generation is in my mind
at least this is going to sound like an
oversimplification but i think it's a
really interesting flip-flop of the
roles that Sony Microsoft played in the
previous generation where Sony sort of
arrogantly presumed that the success of
the ps2 it meant inevitable success for
the ps3 and charge the ridiculous amount
for this over powered machine and
convoluted machine really yes that was
apparently very difficult to develop for
I don't make game so I have no idea but
consistently we heard from do
that the ps3 was architecture was a bit
of a nightmare and then this console
generation it seems like Sony actually
did learn from from that feedback and
Alfred a machine that was cheaper and
easier to design for and like
PlayStation Plus has consistently been a
really good deal for four people yeah
where's the xbox one like they had all
these ambitions that they immediately
walked back when they when they receive
push back at the initial announced like
the cloud mandatory cloud storage and
that was always online like these ideas
that actually weren't terrible what were
presented in absolutely the worst way
possible and then they immediately
backed out of all that stuff and I feel
like it's left the xbox one in this kind
of weird limbo that it has now recovered
from but it took a couple years yeah I
think it just needed to sort of be a
reasonable alternative right to
PlayStation 4 without having these weird
like earmarked like you know either
caveats or benefits that maybe people
didn't understand right that just people
weren't asking for yeah yeah but
definitely great and we got Scorpio
coming out in the next status in a year
I guess yeah I mean the next milestone
in the history books of xbox right well
we'll see I don't even really have any
like big predictions for that yet
because there's still so much we don't
know true 4k gaming Scott we'll see ya
Kelsey alright if you have any fond
memories of the original xbox or the 360
or the xbox one let us know in the
comments below